[музика]
раніше цей катер належав
військовоморським силам США Нині ж
боронить річкові води України Він
оснащений сучасним навігаційним
обладнанням та стрілецькою зброєю Це
справжній Мисливець за шахедами Та
нічого не відчуваєш збив і збив так
скромно про свою роботу розповідає
Андрій хоча насправді кількість збитих
ним російських безпілотників вже й не
злічити що день Що ніч що так скажем
глубока ніч працювати в будь-яку пору
нормально якщо це
конечно сонечко Дуже добре Якщо дощ Ну
це вже трошки гірше але справляємось
катери річкової флотилії на службі у
військово-морських силах України вже
понад рік скільки їх всього інформація
засекречена Утім офіцери кажуть катерів
треба ще більше тож сподіваються на
підтримку від міжнародних партнерів адже
основне завдання флотилії захист Києва а
також Київського та канівського
водосховищ річкова флотилія вона почала
своє формування тогоріч в 22му році коли
Ми зрозуміли що загроза є і на водних
шляхах з території Білорусі з
території Росії ми
відновлюємо наші вікові традиції
присутності на річці Дніпро військових
з'єднань об'єднань підрозділів маючи
такого
агресивного сусіда з півночі та з
північного сходу Нам
необхідно бути впевненими що
контроль на водних ресурсах здійснюється
постійно і саме для цього задіяні ці
катери
і вони виконують місії абсолютно на 100%
поставлені перед ними тому що вони більш
модернові більш маневрові приміром саме
завдяки роботі річкової флотилії
росіянам стало важче вражати дронами
північ України адже раніше під час
запуску безпілотників Росія активно
використовувала русло Дніпра і саме наша
присутність на річці Дніпро вона
перекриває оцей
доступ вздовж і я думаю тей власне
досвід показує що робота досить
ефективна Росія почала використовувати
іншу тактику застосування шахедів і Якщо
раніше
Вони напрямок і пріоритет виставляли як
грло річки Дніпро та й не тільки Дніпро
То тепер Вони намагаються найти шпорини
із сухопутних коридорів і це цей цей
Фактор по суті показує що річка це не
просто That's Easy як це було було
раніше для них можливість Ось так
постояти та поспілкуватися із
журналістами рідкість для екіпажу
зазвичай військові як не російські
безпілотники збивають так українських
порушників ловлять всі кажуть ми знаєм
знаємо а хочеться на річку хочеться там
рибки половити просто як то кажуть в
романтичну подорож поїхати зупиняли
таких Ну але це не відмазка Як то кажуть
заборона дійсно для всіх зупинити ми
можемо будь-який катер який знаходиться
на воді так як це заборонено в даний час
пересування якщо якийсь катер їде ми
його зупиняємо перевіряємо їхні
документи відповідні для перетину річки
якщо їх немає катри затримується Екіпаж
відправляється до поліції на службі у
флотилії переважно річкові моряки які
багато років пропрацювали на Дніпрі Саме
цей досвід допомагає їм під час
виконання завдань крім того серед членів
екіпажу є й цивільні моряки Які ще
донедавна ходили в море повномасштабне
вторгнення застали мене за кордоном а
саме я перебував в Індії і повертався
потім з Кореї через коронавірусні заходи
неможливо було повернути з Індії або з
Китаю я повернувся з Кореї приєднався до
лав військово-морських сил останні 10
років Антон був капітаном цивільних
суден Утім 24 лютого залишив кар'єру аби
стати на захист України тікати ховатись
Це дуже неправильно роботу знайти можна
завжди а батьківщина Вона одна Коли 24
оголосили повномасштабне вторгнення за
мобілізацію Ти бачиш як твоя країна
зменшується от кожну хвилину кожного дня
Як гинуть твої знайомі як зруйноване
твоє місто Ну я оставатись остронь
просто неможливо в такій ситуації
відповідно це рішення далось дуже швидко
і дуже легко я про нього явно не
пошкодую єдине що гнітить розлука з
рідними адже служба займає більшість
часу екіпажі цілодобово патрулюють
Дніпро крім того на деякі бойові
завдання йде до трьх-чотирьох тижнів
більше часу проводиш з екіпажем чим з
своєю родиною в дано сумую за роботою ну
не дуже сумую за сім'єю так дуже
сильно